from the point of view of the sailors
they were locked in the tv room in the
middle of the night it's terrifying
situation they have no idea what's
happening they hear the engines start up
which is not a good sign because they
all know what happens if this ship makes
it to somalia and then they hear
gunshots and even worse than that they
hear an explosion coming from deep
within the ship and smoke starts pouring
in through the grills they recognize
that this is about the worst situation
they could be and they're sitting on top
of a million barrels of explosive liquid
and the ship's clearly on fire
i can't believe that modern-day piracy
is still a thing
yeah i you know i didn't really know
much about it before i started down the
road of doing this book
um
i just assumed that shipping was like
everything else you know the economy
modernizes
the world gets bigger and more
corporatized and
you know generally safer but
you know that just didn't it hasn't
happened yet with shipping it's still in
some ways
the same as it was back in the days when
no pirates were roaming the caribbean
it's still kind of lawless around the
edges um
it's still dominated by like very
secretive wealthy people
and it still does its business
completely outside of the general public
and law enforcement and we just don't
know what goes on out there but it turns
out there's a lot of crime happening uh
which is kind of the subject of the book
isn't it that ninety percent of the
things that you see 90 pretty much
everything is arrived by ship
yeah that's right chris it's um the
famous expression is 90 of everything
and
you know that go that runs from your
iphone your smartphone your computer
through to a barbie doll you bought for
your daughter
um
through to you know some fresh fruits
that's come in it's all come by boat it
still works that way and you know we're
still we're actually more reliant on
chips than we have ever been in human
history it's um
it's so important
it's interesting like i i don't
understand
how
such a fundamental industry remembering
what happened with the ever given when
that blocked the suez canal and all hell
broke loose for a couple of weeks i
don't understand how it's still such a
cowboy
industry is there something about
is there something very particular about
this industry that's causing it to have
loopholes that people can take advantage
of yeah there's a few things happening
at once really i mean the main one is
the same stories that it's always been
which is that governments and police
forces and federal agencies they only
reach about 10 miles out off the shore
of whatever country you're in and out
you know once you go past that point
there is no law uh quite literally
that's the case you you know and so
that's actually true
well i mean technically when you're on a
ship you're subject to the law of the of
the flag that you're flying at the time
um but you know the reality is that out
at sea
if um if a crewman gets thrown over the
side of a vessel
and his you know his fellow sailors are
threatened into silence
who's going to prosecute that crime
which police force is going to bring the
perpetrators to justice
it's it kind of falls in between the
cracks of global law enforcement
and you know police and
law enforcement agencies have a tough
enough time dealing with all the shady
crap that happens on shore they just
don't have the resources or the means to
to stretch out into the sea
and so
yeah you know 150 200 years ago if um
if you murdered someone you wanted to to
escape justice you could just board the
board of [ __ ] ship at your nearest port
and go off to the new world
uh or go to africa or asia and you know
it's still a bit like that um it's just
really difficult for law enforcement
agencies to monitor what's happening at
sea so attracts a certain kind of person
i've got a friend michael mallis who's a
famous anarchist and he always uses this
example he says
a frenchman murders a canadian in mexico
who investigates it well i mean a good
example of that problem is what happens
when
someone burns a
a greek owned oil tanker that is
carrying a million barrels from ukraine
to china
is insured in london
and is carrying the flag of liberia and
owned by a shell company in the marshall
islands
and it's it's
it's it's funny it's funny when you put
it that way but that literally is the is
the quandary when an incident like that
happens everyone sits around going whose
job is this
that's like one of those logic puzzles
that you get in the back of the
telegraph
yeah julie is julie is joanne's mother
and katie is her sister they have known
each other for 45 years how old is blah
blah how many birthdays is it until the
dog dies so all right i i
talk to me about the fact let's get the
the pirates right so you have this ship
which is trying to get from the ukraine
to china it's got what's the value of
the the cargo the cargo is about 100
million dollars it's a million barrels
of oil okay by the time that's 100
million dollars would have been way more
now
should have done it now
should have really done it now um
talk to me about how pirates
operate
like you've got this huge ship
some people may have seen captain what
was that film with tom hanks captain
phillips captain phillips
it still kind of blows my mind that a
little wooden boat with a couple of guys
in sleeveless t-shirts and wooden guns
are able to stop a huge tanker moving at
full speed what's their mo
captain phillips is actually a great
starting point for for the way modern
piracy works and especially in 2011 this
was this was the peak of somali piracy
which is the kind that everyone's you
know read about and seen movies about
um
there was a an attack on a ship once
every couple of days back in this period
it was rampant
and you know the the ammo of the somali
pirates would be they had a skiff which
is a tiny little motorboat
quite quick
carrying maybe you know six or seven
guys with guns and sandals and scruffy
clothes
and they would be directed out to a lot
any large vessel they could find coming
through the gulf of aden
and they would come alongside it use
grappling hooks to try and board
um
literally climb 30 or 40 feet up the
side of these enormous vessels
and then wave their guns around
get into the bridge
and take the ship back to somalian water
where it would be held until someone
paid a ransom
and the crazy thing was that you know
these ransoms were paid
um they were often paid
not only would there be maybe 20 sailors
whose lives would be at risk if the
ransom doesn't get paid
um
a big a big cargo ship might be carrying
one billion dollars worth of cargo on
its own 20 000 containers that could be
packed with laptops or you know whatever
else they just simply couldn't afford to
have these vessels you know sat off the
coast of somalia for months and months
at a time so they paid i
i once spoke to a guy whose job it was
to pay pirate ransoms and he would
sometimes literally
take a small plane and fly over somalia
and drop suitcases of cash out the
window
so this insane industry sprang up and it
was incredibly lucrative for the somalis
so in 2011 um the oil tanker in our
story the brillante virtuoso comes into
this area and of course everyone on
board is terrified because they've seen
captain phillips right they've heard the
stories of what happens to sailors when
somali pirates get on board it's the
middle of the night and
all the filipino sailors on board are
absolutely terrified that something's
going to happen
what's special about this place that
they are in the water
the gulf of aden
um well the gulf of eden just happens to
be
uh the part of
of the coastline of somalia and of the
middle east
and it's at the entry point of the
sewers canal so if you're coming from
asia and you're transiting the sewers
canal which you have to do otherwise
it's a like a 3000 mile journey around
the whole of africa you have to come
through
the waters off the coast of somalia and
you have to get quite close
and you know this is a major world trade
group you know we saw that when the
sewers canal got blocked for a week how
bad it was for the whole world you know
there's there is no option but to
transit sewers so you know major vessels
have to risk passing through this area
there's a few things that you can do to
make it safer
uh go very quickly would be one um
a lot of vessels would go in naval
convoy so they'd have a big british or
american or european destroyer
escorting them through the area which is
going to put off any pirates
sometimes they would carry guards armed
guards
and the brillante virtuoso decided it
was going to pick up a security team off
the coast of aden which is a yemeni port
and so they had to just wait
uh overnight
um you know a few miles off the off the
off the coast of aden for these guys to
arrive by boat that does seem a little
bit like trying to fix the problem by
hitting it with a big hammer like the
the very thing that you're trying to
avoid
by getting the security force on board
is the thing that you're inviting by
sitting there in the middle of the night
this this becomes important
as the story progresses but yeah you're
absolutely right
um it's not the cleverest thing to do
to uh to wait in a heavily pirated area
overnight drifting without power
and not only that but the captain
decided to light all the lights at the
bellante virtuoso so it was lit up like
a christmas tree you could literally see
it from 10 miles away
um you can imagine how the crew felt
just sitting out there waiting what
security measures does a normal ship
have you don't have an escort with you
you're not moving quickly is there
anything that they've got
um
mostly they don't have guns or actual
weapons it's kind of legally problematic
to shoot at uh people from uh from a
container ship or an oil tanker
let alone the moral question so they
don't normally have guns but in the
absence of that and you see a bit of
this in captain phillips they have these
powerful water hoses that that actually
can blast these powerful streams of
water at small vessels and can capsize
them um the brillante
ran
barbed wire all the way around the the
outside of the vessel to make it harder
for pirates to board
i think at one point they even had like
a
a mannequin dressed up in in sailors
gear propped up on the bridge to look
like it was um there was someone i'd
watch even when there wasn't papyrus
scarecrow yeah pirate scarecrow it's
basic um
and uh not terribly effective it turns
out how did they get on then
so
it was a strange incident the um the
crew of this ship are all filipino and
there's a watchman
uh it's about coming up to midnight he's
just finishing his his shift
and he sees
a small vessel approaching very fast so
he goes down and hails them and
he can see from from the deck of the
ship that
this is a small boat carrying armed men
wearing masks they're they're carrying
what look like ak-47 rifles
um they're in strange sort of camouflage
outfits
and
um they shout up that they're the
security crew
uh that they've arrived they're the
security cue and they've arrived and are
ready to board now
as anyone would looking down at these
men with their masks and their ak-47
they don't look much like professional
security operatives and he's the guy on
what she's really reluctant to let them
on board but you know he he he calls up
to the captain in the bridge and the
captain's instructions are clear and
immediate let them let them come on so
he lowers a ladder and literally invites
them onto the ship and they've been on
board for no more than two or three
seconds when they point their their
rifles at him and demand to be taken to
see the captain well
straight away there's something dodgy
going on how would they know that they
were waiting for a security force how
would they know that that would be a
thing that they could shout up
that's that's the big question how would
they know that there was a ship here
waiting for security crew you would have
to have very specific knowledge
all right so what happens next
so what happens next is this chaotic
situation where you've got
seven or eight armed men on board the
ship the filipino crew are rounded up
and locked in the television room
the captain and the chief engineer taken
away by these armed men
and from the point of view of the
sailors who were locked in the tv room
in the middle of the night it's
terrifying situation they have no idea
what's happening they hear the engine
start up which is not a good sign
because they all know what happens if
this ship makes it to somalia
and then they hear gunshots
and even worse than that
they hear an explosion coming from deep
within the ship and smoke starts pouring
in through the grills
um
so you know they they recognize that
this is a
about the worst situation they could be
and they're sitting on top of
a million barrels of explosive liquid
and uh the ship's clearly on fire so
they decide to take a risk and get out
of the tv room so they get out of the
room the pirates have disappeared and so
they sort of inched their way up to the
bridge up this up the steps in complete
darkness because the power's gone out
and they find the captain sort of hog
tied on the bridge
uh waiting to be rescued
hang in a second
they've left the pirates have left the
pirates just upped and left they
disappeared they're supposed to
take this back for ransom that's their
usual mo right yeah
but they've they've left the captain's
there everybody's there no one's been
harmed no one's been hurt no one's been
shot
no they just left they there there was a
mysterious explosion and then they left
you can see why almost immediately
people
who had a financial interest in the ship
were asking the question
what the hell happened here this time
yeah exactly so okay so how do they get
like a normal piracy attack how do they
get saved is there is the ship still
mobile at the moment
no it's it's dead in the water it's just
floating it's it's it's there's a really
serious fire happening now and it's so
hot they can feel the heat and they can
hear the sound of the steel
on the ship uh sort of warping and
bending in the extreme heat
uh which is you know a really an awful
sound to hear
um
but they do a couple of things there's a
security button on the on the on the
bridge that they that they press which
alerts the local
uh authorities and naval forces that
there's a problem and they issue a
distress call which is picked up by
an american destroyer called the uss
philippine sea
which is an hour or so away
and you know the filipino guys say
philippine c philippines
we're under attack please come and help
and within the hour the americans are
there they've got a helicopter and um
they're in a position to help out
right so everybody gets picked up and
taken away yeah they they they abandon
ship uh everyone abandons ship they get
into the lifeboat and they're picked up
and taken aboard this uss cruiser um
one of the one of the individuals the
chief engineer
somehow is left on board and he's on the
ship for about two hours on his own in
very strange circumstances
um
he later tells people he was just hiding
from the pirates in the engine room but
he uh at the crack of dawn he sort of
appears on deck waving a flag
um
and jumps into the water and is picked
up and and taken away by the americans
as well
okay is what did the rest of the crew
say did they was he not with them in the
tv room was was he
no
you know this is one of the strange
things about what happened is he
basically disappeared from sight for
hours
he you know he would later say that he
was taken to the engine room to keep the
engine running and he managed to escape
from the pirates and hide in a toilet
um
and then and then basically sort of
sculpt around for a few hours until the
fire became so serious that he had to
leave and then he was rescued everyone's
so dodgy and there's no one that isn't
dodgy so far uh okay
lloyds of london are the people that are
in charge of the sort of protection
strategies for this because there's a
lot of different people who
own the ship who want their money back
for potential
loss or wastage or the
actual cargo that the ship's got on it
where did how did they get involved well
so lloyd's is lloyd is the market where
you buy insurance for anything big if
you want to launch a space rocket or or
you know carry a million barrels of oil
from ukraine to china or build a
skyscraper whatever it is you can't do
it you can't get your bank loans without
getting insurance you know it's just
impossible it wouldn't happen and so for
anything really big you go through
lloyd's it's like 500 year old market
it's been the biggest in the world for a
long time and it remains the biggest in
the world so that's the place you get
your insurance from and that's the place
that connects all the different insurers
to a ship like the brillante virtuoso so
uh whenever whenever something bad
happens at sea uh whenever there's an
accident or a fire or a hurricane or
whatever it is
um lloyd's has sort of an apparatus that
kicks into action to start solving
problems
um start trying to rescue the vessel
it's it's a little bit similar to
uh if your bathroom floods
you know who do you call the first
person you call is your insurer and then
you talk to your insurer and the insurer
negotiates someone to come out and first
of all fix the problem and then
afterwards
uh try and get some compensation to
repair the damage it's the same in
shipping okay so who do lloyd send
so initially the first person or the
first people on the scene are are
salvage experts
um
salvage crews are like the emergency
service of the ocean they're these guys
who roam around looking for shipping
accidents and they show up on the scene
as fast as they can
and they're there to they're there to
rescue a sinking ship essentially
they'll come on board plug leaks put out
fires
uh rescue the crew
and the reason they do that is not not
because of uh that you know they're
great guys and they're doing it from the
kindness of their hearts it's because if
under under sort of the maritime rules
of the lloyd's market and ocean-bound
trade generally
if you manage to to salvage a ship you
get
anything up to sort of 10 of the value
of what it's carrying now if you imagine
these days
uh a big ship might be carrying a
billion dollars worth
if you're a salvage crew and you you get
one of these ships that run aground and
you manage to in your shirt and you're
first on the scene and you rescue it
that's a huge payout so it's a crazy
risky dangerous but very lucrative
business the first guys that show up is
this greek salvage crew that are based
in aidan and so they start doing some
basic fire fighting
the ship doesn't sink then
it doesn't sink no the fire
initially looks like it's gone out and
then there's an upsurge in the in the
inferno um and the salvage crew spent a
good couple of days doing doing fire
fighting efforts so they're pouring
water on board they eventually board the
vessel and try and try and look at the
damage
and they're responsible for that ship
while it's in the emergency situation
has there ever been a case where
multiple salvage crews have arrived at a
ship at the same time and they're
competing for it sounds like is it like
finders keepers
yes uh it is a bit like that and because
of the way salvage is
you know these are these are rough
uh sort of weather hardened sailors
they're tough people they have to be
it's that kind of that kind of game
and so it can be quite violent you know
there can sometimes be conflict between
salvage crews if they show up at the
same time you know i've heard of guns
being appointed
to keep other salvage crews away
sometimes um salvage crews will sort of
board a vessel that's in trouble and try
and forcibly remove the chains from the
other salvage crew so they can take
control of it
it can get a bit nasty but you when
you're talking about
50 million dollars worth of rewards you
can you can imagine why they do that
yeah it's a serious uh incentive i
suppose to play dirty so what about the
investigation
yeah so so you know after you after
you've stopped the flood in your
bathroom you need to someone to come and
assess the damage you need an assessor
and it's the same with this gigantic
ship there's you know
a dozen companies potentially facing a
loss over this vessel
and what they need is an expert to go
and first of all say you know is this
ship finished is it a total write-off
can it be repaired and recovered
and what's the nature of the damage
uh what caused the damage and so the
person who does that job is called a
marine surveyor and it just so happened
that in nearby aidan there was a very
experienced british guy called captain
david mockett
who had been doing this job a long time
he was kind of famous
in the port city um because he was about
six foot four he was like by by half a
foot the tallest guy in the area had
this this big booming laugh huge
personality everyone knew him and he was
the guy
that you hire if you want a job done
properly um
off the coast of yemen so the insurers
quickly appointed him to go and do
get his boots on the deck and go and do
a proper survey one fella for the entire
boat for the entire investigation
well he so he's he's there in the first
instance just to get aboard
um quickly to get an idea of the damage
of course kind of like the crime scene
photos and then perhaps after that they
can be assessed by a big team of people
exactly so they would eventually expect
to tow the tow the ship somewhere much
safer and then there'd be dozens of
people crawling all over it but in the
meantime they need someone to take a
look um
and david is the guy they hire he takes
the fishing boat out
he manages to talk his way in with the
greek salvage crew
and he gets aboard the vessel looks
around and like you say he has a camera
he's taking pictures all the time takes
hundreds of pictures of the twisted
wreckage of the inside of the ship
uh and he can i think you can see early
on it's you know it's completely
destroyed the ship will never be used
again it's damaged beyond repair what's
that what's happened then the fires just
got rid of some um important parts of
infrastructure the the engine room is is
completely is destroyed completely it's
just a black and [ __ ] mess um
uh and you know at that point the cost
of repairing it would um be far more
expensive than
than you know just strapping it or
buying a new ship
okay it's a write-off does he see
anything suspicious
well he's also he's also looking
for
signs of how this fire started because
as you pointed out it's not it's not
very uh smart pirate behavior to burn
your prize once you bought a vessel
you've gone to all the trouble to get
aboard why burn it and leave so one of
the theories that was going around and
was was being used to explain this was
that they'd fired a rocket-propelled
grenade and that started the fire so
he's mockit was looking for
signs of a rocket-propelled grenade
strike he didn't find any
he was looking for signs of ak-47 fire
he didn't find much of that either
um
and so what what he what he came away
with was this confused sensation of
you know this doesn't the evidence
doesn't point to piracy so what is it
and he you know he has to return to wade
and he sends his reports back to london
and his photographs and all the evidence
he's got
and his initial assessment is
there's something strange about this
incident the local authorities are
suspicious and i'm gonna need to dig
further to find out more
how much is the value of the ship
uh that's an interesting question
the ship for insurance purposes the ship
was valued at about 50 million
dollars
okay so that's
still quite a
hefty
investment as well
yeah but it was a it was an old ship it
was towards the end of its life and it
wasn't in great shape it was kind of a
rusty wreck
so the the actual value of the ship if
they tried to sell it would be would be
much less than that maybe down to 10
million or below
all right so what happens to david next
so uh he's back in aidan and he's you
know he's doing his job trying he's
talking to experts in the area he's
tapping up his local government
sources and a few days after his survey
he gets in his white lexus
to drive home for lunch gets a few yards
down the street
and
a car bomb that's been placed directly
on his seat is detonated
which kills him instantly
pretty serious
yeah
it's an awful attack i mean
at the time the local media was saying
this is another terrorist attack this is
another one of these militant groups
that operate on the arabian peninsula
and on the face of it that seemed like a
plausible explanation but
as soon as you look a bit more closely
at the way he was killed
uh it doesn't make sense
the the bomb wasn't a sort of
large-scale destructive device designed
to maim and cause terror it was a very
specific targeted tnt remote detonated
device it was used the sort of device
they use in yemen for political
assassination
so that didn't fit with the sort of
terrorist mo
and then another big problem was in the
immediate aftermath no terror group
claimed it now in yemen as in elsewhere
when a westerner is killed when a
british or american person is killed the
terror group behind it wants the world
to know they've done it that's why they
that's why they do these attacks in the
first place but no one claimed it
um
and so you know
it started to look like he'd been killed
for another reason but he'd been
targeted specifically for another reason
is there anything interesting about
yemen or the the structure there is
because somalia doesn't have a single
government right that's kind of still
basically up for grabs by whichever
person's the most ruthless
what what's yemen like
yemen yemen back then um was
under the dictatorship of a guy called
president sala
who
was you know a fairly bog standard
developing world kleptocrat
um he ran this sort of corrupt network
of cronies
who made billions of dollars uh from
from the poorest country in the middle
east
um
it wasn't uh
it wasn't as chaotic as it's since
become
but at this particular moment you know
it was the country was on the cusp of
civil war it was the uh start of the
arab spring so all these uprisings
against corrupt dictatorships that
started in tunisia and spread across the
middle east
had arrived in yemen and there were
there were massive street protests
and president saleh you know reacted the
way the dictators often do which is to
send in troops and open fire on peaceful
protesters
uh
the situation in yemen was was chaotic
and complicated for sure and it's
definitely got worse since who
investigates david's death then
uh in the first instance is the job of
the yemeni police
the local yemeni cid is their job
but because this is a british citizen
and because president saleh purportedly
has good relations with with european
countries in the us
the british cops decide to send
one of their detectives over to liaise
with the yemeni colleagues now of course
this guy jonathan totteman he doesn't
have jurisdiction to investigate in
yemen but he's there to offer assistance
and i guess to try and sort of find out
as much information as he can for for
the british government and for marcus
family so he goes out and sort of joins
the joins the investigation do you find
anything interesting
yeah so we we know about um jonathan
topman's work because uh at an inquest
into david mock's death a few months
later he comes and he he explains what
he did in yemen and why
um
i guess the picture that emerges is
of
uh an investigation that doesn't really
do anything you would want uh police
investigators to do
there's no sort of forensic assessment
of the of the crime scene
uh dave market's laptop is destroyed and
is never recovered and they refused to
release it to the british police
there's no serious investigation of
who potentially might want to hurt david
mockett and why the whole thing is kind
of you know
seems to be for show but jonathan topman
does learn one interesting thing which
is uh he's having dinner one night with
some yemeni policemen
and they share their feelings about
what's happened
and they say no they don't think this is
terrorism um
they think that that uh david mocker has
been murdered because of his job that
he's been murdered because of some
corrupt scheme to extract money from the
shipping uh insurance industry
and that that was the reason for him to
be forbidden to target it was a criminal
act and so tottenham takes this
information back to the inquest and he
shares it with the market family and and
the wider world
as reported in the british press
and said now you have this insane
situation where
an oil tanker has been attacked and
burned in
uh well looks it looks increasingly like
a fraud
the one person sent to investigate find
out the truth has been murdered by
unknown criminal actors
and what happens next um
well nothing happens
there's no british police investigation
there's no pressure on the yemeni
government yemen descends further into
chaos and civil war
the there's no criminal investigation
into whatever insurance fraud might have
happened everything gets sort of clogged
up in the administrative
machine of the lloyd of london insurance
market
why does anything start moving then if
everything's clogged up and everything's
going
slow and ground to a halt why does
something begin to pick back up
well the main reason for that is that
the cl the ship owner files insurance
claim at lloyd's
the greek ship owner files the claim and
and the value of that claim rises to
over 100 million dollars or in the
region of 100 million dollars because
this guy is claiming not only for the
value of the ship that's being destroyed
he's also claiming for lost profits and
interest and so the number keeps ticking
up and it becomes
a law because the ship is not being used
and by not having the ship he's losing
business losing business losing more
business
so the number keeps ticking up
and
it becomes so large that it's kind of
hard to ignore now even at lloyds of
london the world's largest insurance
market where
i don't know i think they pay out
something like two hundred thousand
dollars every hour or some insane some
you know there's vast pools of capital
out there almost unlimited
a hundred billion dollars over one ship
is still an enormous amount of money so
the insurers really have no choice but
to to dig a little deeper
and they have the good fortune to um
to hire a legal team who uh use these
investigators these two former policemen
from the met police in london who now do
private work for the insurance industry
and others and these two guys are
brought in by the lawyers to to do
deeper investigation into what happened
to the ship
and you know
they're they have the mentality of crime
fighters they see something that to them
looks like a criminal act and they their
motivation is to solve it at the same
time you know they're aware of what
happened to david mockett
they meet mockett's family his widow
and they see a kind of travesty of
justice and so they become highly
motivated not just to
solve the problem of this 100 billion
insurance claim but also to get to
something that looks like justice
they're the heroes of the story then so
far
in as much as this story has heroes but
they're the only two between them and
the topman guy they're the only three
people that haven't been dodgy yet
everybody else is either dead or dodgy
they they would probably uh dispute the
characterization of them as heroes but
like i definitely think
when this incident happened
uh the various actors reacted in
different ways
some were motivated by politics some are
motivated by
money
there are very few people who made
decisions based on integrity which is
i've seen something happen here and it's
wrong you know a really good guy was
murdered he left behind a wife and
daughters and grandchildren
and i know i don't want to be part of
that
very few people made a moral decision
about what to do next apart from our two
investigators who were richardville and
michael connor um
to the point where they would be giving
presentations in the lloyds of london
market that go to these glitzy office
buildings uh in a room full of lawyers
and insurance executives and they would
bring up on the screen a picture of
mockit's burnt out car just to remind
everyone this isn't just an insurance
contract this isn't just a dollar
dispute
a guy was murdered here a really good
man was murdered and we need to do
something about it
what's happening with the investigation
into the boat after mockit dies because
he was the first person on the scene but
presumably there was subsequent
investigations done after that that were
more forensic
yeah the ship was uh was towed up to the
united arab emirates and
uh you know was was inspected by various
agencies uh including the insurers the
u.s navy's crime scene investigators
unit showed up and had a look around
they were concerned that pirates might
now start if they were blowing up
oil tankers that were passing through
the middle east that's something the
navy wanted to know about too
so the ship was picked over but you know
the fire is a wonderful way of hiding
evidence um
the ship was so badly damaged there
wasn't really much left for them to look
at
they found some kind of suspicious dents
that looked like an explosive device had
been detonated
but that was really the extent to the
evidence
um after that the ship was sold for
scrap and it went off to the place where
ships go to die
which are these um sort of semi-legal
shipbreaking yards in pakistan and india
where they get um driven up onto the
beach and picked apart by hand and all
the metal bits taken away and sold
and so uh yeah the ship was literally um
torn to pieces and the evidence was gone
um
the barrels of oil must have been
taken away and put onto some other ship
to transport it away yeah they managed
to one of the salvage crews managed to
to salvage the the oil they siphoned it
off onto another ship as you say and
that was taken away
um
but that still left a very large
insurance claim for the ship itself
which was damaged beyond repair
um but the problem they had like i say
is the evidence
was gone destroyed or burnt or scrapped
um there was lots of expert opinions
about the cause of the fire and lots of
sort of legal back and forth about
the various debts of the ship owner
but what they what they were lacking was
you know really clear evidence that a
crime had taken place what they needed
was to speak to people
who were on the vessel at the time
who were around in the immediate
aftermath he might actually be able to
say you know here's what happened to the
ship here was the cause of the fire
who's this dodgy greek salvage guy then
how does he come into it
uh vasilios vergos is his name he was um
i spoke i told you about the salvage
crew that arrived really quickly from
from uh from aidan on the yemeni coast
uh and basilius fergus is the guy who
runs that salvage outfit which is called
poseidon salvage
now he's yeah he he's a whole other
character he's
he's a former uh greek navy diver he was
in the greek navy's elite diving school
and he was badly injured in a in a in a
diving accident i think he got the bends
and left him with a lifelong limp and a
bad temper
and he's he's made this strange life for
himself in yemen he basically lives on a
rusty salvage barge
doing bits and bobs for the for various
yemeni projects um but he's gonna
famously got a got a bad temper
so um
he's first on the scene and he gets he
gets the bellante virtuoso in like four
hours
um from nearby aidan which is
astonishingly fast i mean like he was on
the scene so quickly that he must have
woken up immediately on getting the call
started his engines and bolted straight
for the ship like a remark a remarkable
feat of efficiency
um
but there's lots of questions about him
you know the first one being
well how did he know to be ready in the
middle of the night in yemen how did he
get there so fast um
you know he he has one of these
characters
that investigators look at and they see
his track record
and you know they maybe he's not in the
elite uh ranks of salvage crews
he's not um there's a famous dutch
company that that's um are famous all
over the world
you know he's kind of on the on on the
lower rungs of the ladder he's got one
of these ramshackle operations
who's the other
greek guy that's super mario guy that's
not the same person is it no so uh super
mario it was the guy who owned the
brillante virtuoso he's the he's the big
tycoon
um
and uh yeah he's got a fleet of of
tankers and um
and container ships that he operates
around the world and he's part of the
the greek shipping class
which is to say that he's very rich he
lives in greece pays almost no tax
uh and he lives this kind of life of
bond villain luxury uh running his fleet
his particular hobby is racing cars he's
a rally driver
and he's actually quite good he's um he
he does competitive racing around around
greece
and he'll win competitions he's a good
driver and uh and racing rally cards was
always his first passion
um but he sort of fell into the family
business of running a fleet um
and he's a relatively prominent
prominent character in greece i mean he
owns the main fast ferry line between
the mainland and the holiday islands so
anyone who's been sort of boating around
greek may well have been on one of his
vessels companies called sea jets
so he had you know he has he has this
this big reputation
um and it turns out that he's the owner
of the brillante
risk taker
yes adrenaline junkie guy yes mixed with
disgruntled
uh
one and a half legged uh greek salvage
owner
yes
again we're just continuing to add more
and more dodgy people to this to this
list yeah didn't some dude from lloyd's
say that this had happened before at the
funeral didn't he tell the wife that it
had happened before
yeah
i mean one of the things the
investigators
ran into early was
may be hard to believe
um sometimes the lloyds of london
insurance market doesn't know who owns
the ships they're insuring
all they see is a brass plate company
name
with a generic title but they might not
know who the beneficial owner is so with
the first job they had
in the aftermath of the attack was to
find out who actually owned the berlanti
and the insurance guys didn't know they
thought it was they thought it was some
other entity
and then they discovered it was
mariocilliopolis
and you know there was immediate name
recognition they knew that name the
reason they knew his name was that
another ship owned by him had got into
trouble only a few miles away a couple
of years earlier
it had mysteriously um there'd been a
fire on the bridge it run into a sand
bank
and the salvage operation had gone
disastrously wrong and the ship ended up
splitting into like a watermelon
and the other thing that caught the the
investors
the investigators attention was that it
was exactly the same salvage crew who
arrived with remarkable speed from aidan
to help out as her old friend vasilius
vergos the olympian greek diver so he's
on the scene as well so you've got same
ship owner same salvage crew and
remarkably the chief engineer the
filipino chief engineer was the same on
both voyages the one that stuck about
for two hours
so yeah yeah so you know
one unfortunate accident off the coast
of yemen is bad luck
two is probably something else
dude i can't face so ridiculous how sort
of
flagrant and blatant the dodginess is
all right so what what what happens next
we it seems like all of the pieces at
least start to come together but
presumably the investigators other than
coincidence the investigators don't
really seem to have much to tie people
together yet
they don't have a lot of physical
evidence no
and they're also they're also battling
against this this kind of institutional
complacency that you get in in the city
of london in lots of industries to be
fair but also in the insurance industry
where
you know lloyds of london has been
running for 500 years for 500 years has
been a reliable source of income for the
british middle and upper classes you
know the elites of london life um they
quietly make tons of money at lloyd's
they would uh much prefer to do so
without any fuss or attention
and
um
it's a great business for them to be in
you know they they get to go to the pub
for lunch and
uh they have wonderful bespoke suits and
you know they have this sort of
privileged existence and
you know they're not very incentivized
to look closely at the nasty criminal
parts of the shipping industry there's
just no reason for them to do it um
you might imagine that
if there's fraudulent insurance claims
being made it would be expensive for
them to pay and so they wouldn't pay
them they would fight but actually the
reverse is true it's actually in most
cases a lot easier just to pay to make
these problems go away and then pass the
cost on to the customers by raising your
premiums which is what lloyds has been
doing for hundreds of years
it sounds like the
shipping industry that the um
dodginess is so endemic
that what are you gonna do you're gonna
fight this one guy well what about the
next guy and what about the next guy
every single one of the claims that
could be made
is going to come from someone that has a
shell company in
bermuda and didn't you say that
most of the company like each boat is
owned by a single company yeah it's a
single ship system
um
yes it's partly the scale of the problem
but also
unfortunately
fraud and criminality has kind of been
built in to the cost structure of the
lloyds of london insurance market um
they know it happens
they know that it's expensive
um and they tolerate it
um
they figure that
let's say one in 50 this is i'm making
this number up let's say one in 50 ship
casualties isn't an accident it's been
done on purpose to get the insurance
money they figure it's simpler to
particularly just to pay that 1 in 50
and keep doing what they've been doing
rather than go through big expensive
legal battles
rather than go through all the terrible
publicity of accusing a customer of
fraud and rather than actually facing up
to the fact that there's this really
nasty criminal underworld that's kind of
attached itself to the shipping business
so rather than do any of those things
they just pay and they and they keep
doing what they've always been doing so
you know our two investigators in this
story richard veal and michael connor
they constantly encounter this
reluctance to
to go and get the answers they need
they are prevented from doing the
investigation they want to do they're
not allowed to interview the crew as
crazy as that sound they weren't given
they weren't given access to the crew
there are a load of sources that they
identify who might have information
about how the ship was attacked
they are prevented from going to do that
and you know the situation becomes
really tense and kind of uh
conflicted
where they're fighting against their own
legal team and saying we need to do more
they've been brought in by lloyds of
london though so it does seem that
lloyds of london felt like presumably
they can't bring in this level of
investigation for every
uh one of these if you've said that it's
easier for lloyds to pay out it seems
like
they've maybe got something in the side
of their minds that's made them think
we there's something up here let's bring
these grizzled old met
officers in to come and do a bit of work
i'd love to tell you that the the thing
that made this exceptional was that
david market was murdered
and then you know there may be some
truth in that but the evidence doesn't
necessarily point that way
the evidence just points to the fact
that
once uh once this claim reached a
certain size
once they were on the hook for a certain
sum of money
they decided it was time to fight
because um they didn't want to just pay
um and their their own lawyers
have written in legal filings that they
would have been happy to settle this
case
had the sum of money not being so large
wow okay so what happens next
so next it's um
uh it's full speed ahead in this in this
lawsuit between the greek ship owner and
the lloyds of london insurers
and things get really messy and
dangerous quite quickly um
the ship owner super mario is incredibly
hostile
to
any attempt by the insurers to get
information out of him
he uh
isn't handing over evidence you know a
hard drive is full of emails going
missing
uh it all becomes quite threatening
and this is where i entered the story
because at the time i was i was covering
the courts in london
and i'd sort of become aware of the
brillante virtuoso incident and i
happened across on the court lists one
day
seeing the name of the company that
owned the ship
um in in one of the big courts in london
i just turned up
and what i stumbled into was super mario
the ship owner had been summoned by a
london judge to give evidence
uh in the case
and
i've been to hundreds and hundreds of
commercial trials i've never seen
anything quite like this
um
he was uh
bellicose and angry and belligerent
waving his finger at one point he
threatened the english lawyers
we just you just don't see these things
in the rarified sort of world of london
london law
um
it was it was frankly very entertaining
and a little amusing
um
and then uh at the end of this two days
of you know incredibly fraught
cross-examination
he walks out of court and is arrested by
the city of london police for fraud
uh accused of fraud
well he's arrested on suspicion of a
fraud against the lloyds of london
insurance market oh so for this this
wasn't him getting picked up for
something else this is picked up for
this right this is for the brillante
virtuoso
and so i've i've walked into this mad
situation
where there's a simultaneous very
hostile lawsuit and criminal
investigation
and this remarkable character of a ship
owner
um
and that's where i sort of pick up the
story um
it takes it takes a good few months
after that to sort of unravel what's
happening because all that i've told you
so far is happening behind closed doors
in the city of london um so it took us
quite a while to get up to speed on
exactly who where did you get where did
you do your investigation then how did
you get any of this information from
behind closed doors
uh well it took about four or five years
of um
[Music]
uh talking to people mainly
uh we did about 150 interviews uh we you
know we compiled loads of documentation
the lawsuit helped because any time
there's a lawsuit you get a sort of
backbone of documentary evidence that's
that's relatively reliable
but the lawsuit didn't deal with a lot
of things we wanted answers to you know
we wanted to know more about david
mockett's life and death
uh we wanted to know more about the the
sailors on the ship and what what their
experience had been like
so we had to take what had been done so
far and try and push it forward and go
to places the police hadn't been go to
places the insurance investigators
couldn't go and get the answers no one
else could
what ended up happening with super mario
then was he released back to greece
super mario was released without charge
he
no commented his interview didn't give
many information they searched his room
but um
no they let him go and i don't think
he'll ever come back to london
yeah i think that that's right and then
david's death has anyone been charged
with that
no no one's ever been charged with
david's meth david mockett's death
unfortunately
which is a continuing source of pain for
his widow you know if you can imagine
losing someone in your life that you
really care about that's hard enough you
know devastated his family they were
there they were just about to retire as
well and she'd spent her whole life away
from david he'd been at sea or working
in ports around the world for their
whole married life together and he was
just about to retire and they were going
to finally spend some time together so
she's been left with a terrible hole in
her life
but i think it's been made worse by the
fact that there's been no reconciliation
there's been no
uh
no attempt to punish the act of murder
in fact if anything for a few years
afterwards the whole thing was
completely forgotten about no one wanted
to talk about it no one even paid her a
visit the insurance companies that uh
hired dave mockett uh never once
contacted her to say anything let alone
apologize or
you know offer her something by way of
an explanation so
that makes the grief a lot harder to
process i think because there's this
unresolved pain that she's never been
able to get over
is there an insurance policy
for
people like
mockit going out to dangerous
countries
uh there was but um
his local employer and yemen did a
runner and um
she never got any of that money
yeah
oh my god is isn't insurance a funny
thing
no no it's not it's just tragic it's not
funny in the slightest okay so
uh super mario's back in greece he's
he's been released without charge after
no commenting
uh
david market's death hasn't been
investigated and
evidence will have been fritted away
it's in a a country with
even worse
sort of political standing than it was
11 years ago when all of this happened
has the payout
to super mario's company been agreed yet
or is that still ongoing
so there's that the one thing that has
been resolved in all this mess
is
what happened to the brillante virtuoso
and you know after a very long and techy
trial
um
a high court judge in london ruled that
uh the ship had been deliberately burnt
by uh
members of the yemeni coast guard who
had been hired by marius ileopolis and
his associates including
vasilius fergus the limping salva in a
sort of pre-planned active insurance
fraud
where
um
super mario was short of money he was
you know he was desperately short of
cash the brillante was hemorrhaging
losses for him
and he needed a way to get rid of the
ship and they came up with this kind of
hair-brained conspiracy
where
they were going to make it look like a
pirate attack but hire some guys to come
on board and start a fire and wreck the
ship
um
you know they very nearly got away with
it and you know
they they chose wisely in terms of the
location for their fraud because they
did it in yemen yemen is an impossible
place for anyone to operate it's you
know it's been in a brutal civil war for
years it's had outbreaks of cholera and
covid uh saudi bombs falling all the
time they cho they chose very cleverly
um which is probably the reason most of
the perpetrators of escape justice in
fact all of the perpetrators of escape
justice
but importantly for our understanding of
what happened the judge found that yes
it was a conspiracy yes it was done at
the behest of super mario yes vasilius
vergos was involved
and so we we we got a little bit closer
to the truth
how did he know that it was coast guard
repurposed as pirates
he um
so i think to answer that question you
have to look at how crime works on an
international sort of complicated level
and when you're talking about
transnational crime
drug running uh people smuggling
there are sort of loosely affiliated
international networks of criminals the
italian mafia will be loosely affiliated
with the irish mob
and you know the colombian cartels
and
they
they're not sort of
locked together in an ironclad
conspiracy they work with each other
when it's financially beneficial to do
so friendships are convenient
yeah and you know
um
so the greek criminal cartel that
arranged the attack on the ship and
profited from it had local fixers in
aiden and one of them was vasilius
vergos
uh this incredible character who who
teamed up with a local businessman and
they managed to get access to the local
power structure in yemen um and of
course back then in yemen probably as
now
it's not very difficult to get access to
the local power structure if you're
willing to throw some money around
um
so it wasn't very actually very
difficult for them to find
yemeni coast guard members who are
willing to do a job for a bit of extra
cash
has vasilius been charged
no he's never been charged with a crime
i should say that
although he doesn't exactly deny the
allegations against him
um
we are the only ones as far as i know
we've ever spoken to about it we managed
to reach him by phone shortly before the
book was finished
um
as far as i know he's still in greece um
what's he like what's he like to speak
to
well let me tell you this when
we sent him uh by text uh a list of sort
of bullet points of the things that we
were about to publish in our book uh
this sort of standard journalistic
practice you're going to write something
about someone they should have a right
to know they should have a right to
reply so we did this process
and we sent him a text and his reply was
a smiling a crying with laughter emoji
which um sort of tells you something
about his attitude to
um
sort of allegations of criminality and
wrongdoing didn't seem to be overly
concerned about them
uh he didn't engage much more than that
quite frankly he didn't really
engage with you know all the evidence
against him uh and what was said by the
london judge
all he would say to us was this is
ridiculous how would i know and you know
all the evidence has been made up by
people who are trying to blackmail me
and then he sort of cuts off contact
so where is the investigation at now
and what do you think is going to happen
in the
sort of near future
well the sort of cause of cynthia mocker
has been picked up by her local mp
in devon who's raised it in the houses
of parliament
um
and he called it a tragedy of justice
and and he sort of he asked the question
of the of the of the justice minister
the head of the of the justice
department
um
you know what are we going to do about
this
and
i think the police's attitude is that
it's not our job to investigate a murder
in yemen and of course they're right
about that they have no jurisdiction to
go over to aiden and start throwing
people in the back of police vans
but the point of cynthia mockett and of
michael connor actually the investigator
who's been helping her is that you don't
need to prosecute that crime you can
treat this as a financial crime you can
do what they did to al capone
right they got money taxes
treat this as an act of maritime piracy
and an active insurance fraud and then
you can start to bring charges but no
one's been willing to do that and i
think it's clear
the british police see it as too
difficult and too problematic to pursue
a case
but it's not too late um as this mp
pointed out the evidence is still there
um you know
someone could pick this up and pursue it
from a law enforcement point of view
uh it would just take a little bit of
will and bravery so it remains to be
seen whether that'll happen
and the money to
super mario wasn't paid out or is that
case being finished now with lights
the lawsuit is is ended and
um it ended up as kind of like a pyrrhic
victory for the insurers
because they won the case
you know
technically they won the case
the judge the judge found that they
didn't have to pay on the insurance
claim because it was a fraud
but
um
they didn't actually win in any real
sense because
super mario managed to extricate himself
from the legal process
because he refused to hand over evidence
because he basically didn't play the
game of london litigation the way you're
supposed to he just cut himself off from
the process
um his claim was thrown out
but he had an existing insurance policy
that he's from his bank
his uh his lenders who lent him money to
buy the boat had their own insurance
policy so they continued the case
against the london insurers so the
lawsuit ended up as insurer versus
insurer which group of insurers were
going to pay for the damage to polante
virtuoso
super mario
got away
um
and
basically he what he had at the start of
this was an aging rusting
useless
money losing oil tanker
he burned it
um oh and he had sorry he had about 60
million dollars in loans
to cover the cost of that oil tanker he
burned his own ship he was freed from
his loans his you know his debt went to
zero on the ship he was also free of his
money losing ship so by some standards
you could say he's won he's probably
at least tens of millions of dollars
better off than he would have been if he
hadn't sunk his own ship which is one of
the crazy things about this story
uh one of the things that still blows my
mind
yeah
i can't believe it
this story is is insane
uh
oh kit dude
congratulations on the lengthy and very
impressive investigation the book's
great the story's fantastic uh if people
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you do or your further
investigation with regards to the story
you did a great piece on the ever given
and and what that caused as well where
should they go to to keep up to date
with your work
uh you can you can follow me on twitter
at kitchell uh like any vain journalist
i post all my stories on there
um
yeah and check out dead in the water
look at father's day is coming up if
if you know someone in your life who
loves sort of crazy yarns about life on
the open sea
um
you know this is definitely one of those
i've been doing this job a long time and
i've never seen anything quite like this
chris i appreciate you cheers thanks man
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace